Dancing with the Stars delivers
show-stopping routines as two
contestants are eliminated boys to men
star Wanya Morris slayed with this
passionate Paso Doble then he performed
a fast-paced Charleston that earned him
yet again a perfect score still though
all that fancy footwork wasn't enough to
keep the singer in the competition he
and NFL pro Antonio Brown were sent home
it's like planning a playoff game and
knowing you lost the game and you have
to go home it's been an amazing journey
and one to be grateful for the three
remaining couples Paige and Mark ginger
and Val in denial and PETA who weren't
straight tens with this Argentine tango
that the deaf model danced with a
blindfold been blindfolded oh good I
felt like a lot of people have felt I
felt the energy and how people reacted
to it and that was the goal he really
had to be in so in tune with me to not
have a misstep and he did it for UFC
fighter Paige Vanzant there seems to be
some heat on and off the dance floor
with troupe member Alan Burstyn what is
going on between you and this fine bird
you were asked about your chemistry with
Alan and you said yeah there is some
chemistry what exactly is that chemistry
you know a girl does not give themselves
well you kind of put it on Alan's to
tell you're like let him answer the
question how come you two that it's a
man's job
he's got to step up